darby 11 jours sérieux pourquoi on est
là à quoi ça sert je pensais la même
chose que toi que la désintox ne
marchait pas m'excuser mois
un appel pour toi
ma mère a été hospitalisée je dois
partir tu sais bien qu'un règlement
si tu pars tu retournes en prison
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la route est interdite il faut que
j'aille à salt lake city on ne va pas
plus loin jusqu'à ce que la tempête soit
fini allez vous abritez à l'office du
tourisme que j'ai fait ouvrir pour des
gens
comment vous appelez darby mois-ci
samedi ed je m'appelle h
lorsque vous avez le code du oui ici y'a
pas le wifi j'ai réussi à avoir une
barre sous l'arbre pendant 10 secondes
retire de l'argent tu te promènes tu te
crever
ça a pas l'air d'aller
il vaut mieux vous mettre à l'aise vous
voulez jouer on est coincé ici jusqu'à
ce que la tempête se calme
je vais sortir de là
le truc c'est de miser sur le joueur pas
sur les cartes
on a tous senti que vous dites vous
c'est quoi il va falloir que tu
découvres 3 même
je veux pas monder rizki schmoll fausse
tirer et vite eh ben la nuit va être
longue
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]